[Musique]
bienvenue nous sommes sur la terrasse du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
scène nationale en compagnie de son
directeur lionel masse et à ça va bien
on est où les sur cette terrasse d'abord
parce que c'est un endroit magnifique
assez peu connue way vient pas encore
exploité j'espère qu'il le sera un jour
où on avait une vie magnifique et puis
aussi parce que il ya des travaux dans
la grande salle des répétitions dans les
autres salles ça veut dire que la vie
reprend au théâtre la vie a repris le 18
mai puisqu'on a rouvert la billetterie
les plus tôt possible après le
déconfinement parce que voilà ça fait
partie des services publics ça fait
partie des endroits où il faut qu'ils
aient un lien avec le avec des publics
avec la population donc c'était
important de le faire et puis c'était
aussi extrêmement important pour les
artistes de pouvoir répétés puis il y
avait deux mois sans répétition donc
voila tout en respectant les conditions
sanitaires on a réussi à ouvrir
mais ce que vous dites là qu'il ya des
travaux dans la grande salle d'il ya des
répétitions dans la petite c'est aussi
ça fait aussi partie de toutes les
choses qui existent et que les publics
ne voit pas fort sûr c'est à dire que
voilà onze mois par an le théâtre est en
fonctionnement permanent mais ça veut
dire ça donc je dis la vie rebond s'il
ya eu quand même cette période
compliquée à partir du mois de mars le
confinement après alors comment ça s'est
passé contre continue des compliments il
ya des spectacles au prix qu'on peut
reprendre dans quelles conditions
dans les conditions n'étaient pas
véritablement réunis avec des
changements d'information tous les
toutes les semaines tous les quinze
jours et vous le vous le savez
dans notre métier on est sur un métier
d'anticipation alors ce qui s'est passé
dans un premier temps au début du
confinement comme on n'en connaissait
pas la durée on a essayé on a tenté de
reporter une partie des spectacles
annulés sur la fin de l'année entre mai
et juin avant que on apprenne qu'en mai
juin on ne pourrait pas tourner dans des
conditions viables
donc on a annulé certains spectacles
reportés d'autres sur la saison en cours
sur la saison suivante dans c'était une
période assez étrange assez étrange
parce que là encore je parle
d'anticipation l'on ne pouvait pas
anticiper
bien sûr c'est ça on ne sait pas on est
dans l'incertitude qui est ce qui est la
chose la plus terrible pour quelqu'un
comme vous qui doit programmer pour
l'épauler pour les artistes d'hier
est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que cette période
très troublée très très nouvelle aussi à
influence aujourd'hui les artistes dans
leurs créations
est ce que c'est un ce tour car je pense
que c'est un peu tôt on a je pense que
c'est un peu tôt mais influencé ça
voudrait dire je pense qu'il ya une
réflexion en fait cette période de deux
2 mois à un tout petit peu accéléré la
réflexion sur les nouvelles technologies
qui sont présentes
présente sur les plateaux depuis des
années des années mais je pense que la
réflexion a été qu'est ce que on
pourrait montrer au public que les
publics ne peuvent pas voir lorsqu'ils
viennent au théâtre donc c'est tout ce
qui s'est passé dans l'est dans les
coulisses et le plein de concerts
confiné il ya eu plein d'accès à des
répétitions et c'est donc je pense c'est
rentré un peu plus rapidement dans le
logiciel des artistes mais aussi dans le
logiciel d des lieux des théâtres oui
parce que c'est vrai que la vie
culturelle a continué de manière un peu
différente
cette période là alors il faut parler un
peu pratique puisque la saison reprend
comment ça se passe pour les pour les
spectateurs il ya il ya des mesures rien
qu'on commence comment ça se passe et on
fait partie des lieux on est on est
tenue tous les lieux d'ailleurs recevant
du public en est tenu à des normes assez
assez strict mais qu'on a souhaité
rendre fluide non pas souple mais fluide
pour pâques et les publics qui viennent
au théâtre soit soient gênés sont
embarrassés est à venir 1h30 ou 2h avant
cela en fait les publics viennent au
théâtre comme ils viennent d'habitude il
ya juste des réflexes à avoir que nous
on doit avoir quitté les publics doivent
avoir mais moi je crois beaucoup à la
responsabilité des uns et des autres et
au fait qu'on acquiert ses réflexes sont
des êtres jacques d'ailleurs que ça
changerait pas grand chose pour le
spectacle pour le sport les spectateurs
ça change pas grand chose à part qu'ils
sont beaucoup plus confortablement assis
dans puisqu'ils sont moins nombreux que
ce qu'on arrive à monter avec les des
conditions sanitaires on arrive à monter
à 60 65 % de la jeu si on veut respecter
des normes sanitaires
mais non on n'espère ça ne change pas
grand chose ce qui change c'est pour les
artistes
1 d'une part parce qu'il ne sorte
d'euphorie de revenus et sur scène mais
il a une façon de faire mais il ya une
furie pour les publique de retrait opr
réservé sur scène
mais il ya aussi quelque chose de très
étrange dans cette euphorie c'est que
les artistes jouent devant des publics
masqué et prendre avoir discuté avec eux
c'est toujours quelque chose dans tout
petit peu étrange quand il faut qu'ils
s'habituent
ah oui il faut s'habituer oui c'est ça
son intrigue dont on voit pas forcément
là les réactions un moule parce que
c'est interdit qui fonctionne beaucoup
avec des abonnés des abonnements comment
ça se passe alors si on dépanne parce
que vous parliez d'incertitude lui aussi
pour les spectateurs
alors c'est qu'ils prennent des
abonnements et 10ème est-ce que ça va
servir ce que ça va pas servir alors ça
se passe alors d'une part ce n'est pas
un théâtre qui ne fonctionne qu'avec des
abonnements fixes et 50 % des places qui
sont prises dans l'abonnement et 50 %
des places qui sont prises de façon
libre par en fait on attendait des
systèmes d'abonnement ou de cartes
d'adhésion qui sont différenciés et qui
permettent par exemple si on prend une
carte une carte d'adhérent une carte
saison on peut très bien acheter le
spectacle et la place et on n'est pas
obligé de s'engager sur quatre ou huit
ou douze spectacles donc d'accord on a
cette souplesse qui existait avant le
coc vide avant la crise et à utiliser
mais j'étais comme si c'était une
tradition les abonnements qui était
privilégiée par les téléspectateurs
aujourd'hui on sent que ça se reporte un
tout petit peu vers la carte saison
parce que pour eux il ya eu il ya cette
incertitude
mais voilà donc on choisit et l'on
choisit on peut prendre la carte saison
et puis ne prendre qu'une place et puis
prendre la place peut-être quelques
jours avant le spectacle
donc cette souplesse elle existait déjà
alors barre lors de du fond même dansé
de cette saison qui s'annonce on va
peut-être alors on va passer oui le
théâtre la danse peut-être le cirque
commençons par le théâtre quels sont le
vous vous grande non pas là ils sont
tous grands et vrais choix terrible à 8
heures mais c'est vrai que la tour du
canadien peut pas choisir a toujours du
mal à choisir bourget en privilégier
quelques heures celui que puisqu'entre
quand vous êtes arrivé ici on a croisé
adrien des artistes étant en réparation
sur l'équipe de là c'est l'équipe de la
cordonnerie qui travaille sur un théâtre
cinéma c'est à dire qu'il fait un vrai
film et ensuite ce film et bruitées et
sonorisé sur scène c'est à dire quand je
dit un vrai film c'est à dire ils ont
tourné cet été avec une équipe d'une
centaine de personnes en gros c'est une
grosse production qui ensuite est parlée
et ébruitée sur scène et c'est une
adaptation de roméo juliette en théâtre
cinéma qui se passe en banlieue qui se
passe en banlieue entre d'un côté alors
ça ne laissez pas les montaigu et les
capulet à l'ailé visible et invisible
c'est à dire des gens visibles sont ceux
qui habitent dans le centre urbain et
puis de l'autre côté du périphérique à
vivre et puis forcément l'histoire
d'amour ça va être la rencontre entre
invisible une invisible voilà à succès
en mois de répétitions ça va être cette
cette représentation ici un partenariat
avec londres avec des vides à combler
également nos voisins et avec cette
structure très original le cinéma abc cc
oui c'est formidable nous on est on est
très client et ça fait c'est la
troisième fois qu'on accueille l'équipe
en répétition en création ici après il
ya d'autres moments de théâtre si on se
projette à la fin de la saison il ya le
le roi lear en reste avec shakespeare
lavaud dois dire que oui de georges
lavaudant dojo lavaudant avec jacques
weber
ça ça va être un gros morceau de la
saison c'est le retour depuis deux trois
ans de jacques weber dans le dos la
g-league livrer la version non mais j'ai
bel 10 mai était avec lui il était
d'accord
un moment au faux de dire que peut-être
qu'il aurait dû aller plus vite vers des
grands metteurs en scène mais je crois
qu'il le reconnaît lui-même et que l'art
c'est vrai que c'est une autre facette
de son talent parce qu'il a un immense
talent et oui il a un immense talent et
puis c'est un talent qu'il arrive à
exprimer de façon décuplée sur les
scènes du théâtre public peut-être avec
des metteurs en scène plus exigeants
avec des scénographies plus exigeante
avec des temps de travail beaucoup plus
donc que dans le théâtre privé et tout
d'un coup on rôde et enfin pour beaucoup
de public de spectateurs ont re
découvert quand un immense acteur avec
une palette immense ça ça va être vrai
en fin de saison je crois que c'est au
mois deux au mollet alors patients
peut-être à la danse macabre sur le
théâtre
ou alors il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses la danse avec avec
une artiste en résidence
oui c'est une chorégraphie s'appelle
béatrice massin qui est vraiment la
grande chorégraphe baroque jeudi
française parce qu'elle est française
vie mais qui tourne à l'international et
qui va être en web et qui va être en
création donc il passe qui très souvent
au théâtre national de chaillot là qui
va être en création ici une nouvelle
création pendant quinze jours de
répétitions et qui va créer une pièce
chorégraphique baroque pour le jeune
public
c'est assez rare les deux cas ces deux
et les pièces de danse pour le jeune
public
voilà donc on est très heureux et c'est
une nouvelle associés du théâtre de
saint quentin
le cirque est très important à cette
année
ben oui viendrai est très important mais
l'arrière vous avez des 800 absolue mais
puisque lé dernier on avait eu on avait
le cirque plume représentation
archipleine là il ya parfois c'est assez
étonnant quand on fait de la
programmation il ya parfois des
conjonctions et il ya là cette année
cinq spectacles qui à mon sens sont
exceptionnels voilà tout d'un coup on se
retrouve avec une saison avec des
spectacles exceptionnels je pense à au
spectacle avec les sept trampolinistes
un spectacle qui s'appelle les hauts
plateaux
je pense à ce spectacle du de la
compagnie xy cdu main en main c'est à
dire c'est un spectacle il ya dix-neuf
personnes sur scène mis en scène par le
chorégraphe rachid ouramdane donc c'est
déjà la convention entre le cirque et la
danse c'est vraiment scellier sont quand
même assez assez d'horizons plus ténue
et il n'y a rien d'autre que dès que des
que des circassiens sur scène il n'ya
absolument aucun agréé et c'est un
travail sur le mouvement sur le plateau
tous et voilà cette partie des choses
assez extraordinaire il ya une
proposition qui fait par une jeune fil
de fériste funambule peut dire aussi
funambule qui s'appelle johanne blais
spectacle de 50 minutes qui est
tellement bien penser tellement bien
réfléchi tellement drôle
voilà il ya une saison qui est très très
très ouverte et hyper réjouissantes les
enserre cassen
alors il ya aussi une chose qui me plaît
beaucoup c'est là aussi vous fait
découvrir les coulisses des créations on
peut venir nous parler avec des artistes
ou voilà vous regardez un peu les
créations ça c'est important
et puis il ya les rencontres in cité ça
vous à bordeaux n'est pas ça non
l'abandonnent pas bien alors si l'année
dernière et la cendre est sur une
musique musique savante musique
populaire
oui parce que c'est des questions qu'on
se pose tout le temps quand on fait la
programmation qu'elle est là quelle est
la différence est sûre c'est dur à dire
qu'en fait la programmation c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on catégorise les
musiques canton hiérarchise des musiques
entre les musiques savantes et les
musiques populaires
qu'est ce qu'on y est rare cheese en
fait est ce qu'on a toujours l'opéra
c'était une musique populaire mais il ya
aussi ça qui est intéressant c'est à
dire toi oui il ya aussi ces allers
retours entre les entre entre l'opéra
qui fut une musique populaire
les - même si l'opéra fait de fait de
gros efforts aujourd'hui et il ya des
allers retours incessants entre les
musiques savantes et populaires on peut
penser à un compositeur comme bartok qui
allait s'inspirer
oui de les recommander musique
folklorique sur les recrache formés pour
les re digérer donc il ya d'un côté
cette hiérarchisation des musiques et
dans la réalité c'est tirage si cette
part dans cette île hiérarchisation
existe finalement assez peu en dehors de
nos têtes parce que les compositeurs les
musiciens se balade verte allemand entre
toutes ces expressions et puis
aujourd'hui quand on voit des jeunes
contre les jeunes compositeurs ou de
jeunes musiciens et musiciennes qui
sortent des conservatoires
ils sont aussi bien pétri de rock de
musique électro que de musique
contemporaine du baroque au classique
donc ça c'est très intéressant de se
voir quelles sont ces mélanges il n'y a
pas la grande
il ya la bonne élève d'accord ça donne
très envie tout ce que vous dites là ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter c'est quoi ce
qui est bien le moins d'incertitudes
possible sur la situation et que ce
qu'on peut nous souhaiter c'est que les
publics soient aussi optimiste que nous
la valeur est optimiste ben oui on est
d'une part on vit au jour le jour et on
apprend à aimer sous présent et d'autre
part on est forcément optimiste on est
obligés de l'être sinon on peut plus se
projeter
donc voilà on a envie que les publics ne
soient aussi et puis cette crise nous
met face à la nécessité de nous adapter
systématiquement or je crois qu une des
grandes forces du spectacle vivant et de
l'art c'est de savoir s'adapter et
d'être extrêmement réactif donc espérant
que nous le soyons et que les publics je
sois aussi merci infiniment lionel mais
c'est l'inversé battre ici
[Musique]